Tổng thống Mỹ đồ năng tròm ngày 20 năm tư tăng sáo bất ngờ tuyên bố,
Trung Quốc dở đầy có thể tiếp tục mua dầu tuyên bằng lãm giới lên là sống phản mạnh mẽ trên thị trường dầu thế giới.
Thông báo quẩm trăm đứa dứa ra chỉ một bài dơ sau khi ông Công Bố is Seren và Ivan đã đồng ý ngừng bắn.
Chúng tôi cạnh, các thẳng theo thang sau những cuộc không kích của Mỹ, vào các thơ dự hạp nhìn Ivan.
Vậy, người chóa phép Trung Quốc tiếp tục mua dầu Ivan, được xem như một cách để giám áp lực kinh tế li đi vang.
Khó đó, hỗ trợ duy trì lên nương bản liên tục và chẳng làm tình hình thêm căn thần.
Trung Quốc là đối cám mua dầu lớn nhất của Ivan khiến nhập khoảng 1 phần trăm lượng dầu thuốc của Sa-Này.
Cui đền từ ông trăm đã lập tất hiện giá dầu với kép tế I zạm gần sống phần trăm,
xuống còn khoảng 6.000 đường là Mỹ một thông.
Tuy nhiên, một quan trích tất cả của nhà trắng xong đó, cho biết, lạnh trưng phạt với Ivan vẫn được duy trì.
Quynh cao các nước tiếp tục ương tiên nhập khổ dầu từ Mỹ.
Dời qua sát nhận định, tuyên bỏ của tổng thông trăm có thể là mức đi chính lực,
nhằm kiểm soát căng thằng ở khu đục trường đông.
Đồng thời, ông định quan cung sồng toàn cầu, hạn như thiệt trường,
và tạo điều kiện cho đàn phản thường hạn Mỹ chung.
Chào khi đó, các đồng mình nhỏ lập xe u có thể không mấy 2 lòng,
còn đi vang chưa được ra phản lượng chính thức.